نسمع عن استشاري علاقات زوجيه واحنا عاده
او مكاتب بتوفرها بعض المحاكم لمعالجه
الخلافات الاسريه ولمن الشمل بالوسائل
الوديعه هذه المره ضيفتنا من نوع مختلف هي
تشجع على الطلاق وتخطي الشعور بالخوف من
هذه الخطوه براءه تعتبر نفس
ها كتيبا يساعد على معرفه مراحل الطلاق
الخمسه بحسب تصنيفها اعتمدت في هذا الكتيب
على تجربتها ومشاعرها في كل مرحله لمساعده
العملاء عاله تشافي
يعني الطلاق واحد يبي يطلق او ما يطلق
متردد كيف النوم يعني تدربين على انه يتخذ
هذا القرار الصعب هو بالفعل صعب
وتبعاته وعوارض الانسحابيه اصعب طبعا
تكون مرته اهم علاقه ولكن انا لا ادربهم
على اتخاذ قرار الطلاق انا
ياخذوا القرار الاصح لمرحلتهم ببعض
الاحيان يكون الانسان يطلب الطلاق عن رده
فعل وهاي العلاقه بتكون ما زالت تحمل يعني
تطور وفي لها فرصه فليش الانسان يهدم هاي
العلاقه بمجرد انه هو شايف انه هو ما
بيقدر يستمر فيها وببعض الاحيان لا يعرف
الانسان حقيقه خطوره العلاقه التي يعيشها
وبانه يعني
يمكن حياته
طيب براءه كيف كيف بتقدري يعني يقال بانه
اهله بشعابها كل شخص ادرى
بعلاقته
بتفاصيلها بتفاصيل شريكه كيف ممكن حدا من
الخارج مضر اول مدرب الطلب في الوطن
العربي انها تقدر تساعد شخص على انه يتخذ
قرار القرار الاصح يعني
لا لا بدون ذلك يعني كان ممكن يتخذ قرار
خطا بينما هو الخبير اكثر منك على الاقل
في علاقته مئه بالمئه صحيح ميه بالميه
ولكن الانسان لما بيكون بمشكله بتكون
افكار مشوشه مشاعرهم ملخبطه بيكون ببعض
الاحيان يحمل غضب فما بيقدر اساسا يشوف
العلاقه بشكل واضح في اللي انا بعمله
بنشوف العلاقه منظف المشاعر بنرتب الافكار
وبنشوف حلول جديده ببعض الاحيان مجرد انه
المراه تفضفض بتقول بتعرفي شو انا بحب
زوجك انا ما بقى بدي اتطلق
الرجل نفس الشيء مجرد يحس انه هو ما فهمته
باللي كانت عم تقوله عم تتصرفوا وانا فهمت
وجهه نظر المراه بهذا الموقف بيقول بتعرفي
لكان انا بدي ارجع لعلاقتي وهاي العلاقه
بدي اطور منها
[موسيقى]